this is a production of Cornell
University
so today I'm going to go over some ways
that I've been trying to develop an
integrated approach to manage weeds
gonna go over some examples from my
dissertation in which I tried to do this
and then get into some of my more
current work with New York State IPM
program I actually want to start off by
talking about a weed control failure
this is glyphosate resistant horse weed
that has taken over a soybean field near
Geneva and this happens when growers
repeatedly rely on the same selection
pressure in this case glyphosate
selecting for those individual weeds
that have some tolerance to that
selection pressure and this herbicide
resistance has become probably the
biggest problem in the field of weed
science
unfortunately this over reliance on a
single selection pressure does not just
apply to conventional growers actually
from my dissertation I interviewed for
organic vegetable growers that
repeatedly rely on the same weed
management strategy and have have kind
of selected for a certain cohort of
weeds in this first example mark Guzzi
typically relies on a strategy in which
he controls weeds in the early part of
the season when they're their most
likely to affect yield we call this the
critical period and after that period
weeds don't tend to affect yield so much
and so he tends to ignore those weeds
and then when I looked at his
his soil and counted the number of seeds
in the soil and what we call the weed
seed bank it turns out that his weed
seed bank was really dominated by Galan
saga pictured here which tends to come
in later in the season after the
critical period and set seed before he
is able to harvest so it's a little bit
of a different example that I'm not
showing a weed that has changed or
evolved in itself but rather in this
he's kind of selected for a weed that
happens to have traits that can allow it
to survive his assistant selection
pressure another example Tom Hahn
inferred uses a strategy to try to not
let any weeds produce seeds and thereby
not letting those weeds that they're
seeds
preying down into the ground that's this
by really frequent cultivation events
and so when I looked at his his his weed
seed bank it was dominated by this weed
personally I think over 95% of it was
personally and this is one of the best
weeds at surviving hoeing you can
actually pull up this weed cut it into
pieces and a lot of times it will still
be able to reroute and produce seeds
another example
Dave Colson relies on plastic mulch to
suppress weeds in his beds but he
oftentimes doesn't control weeds between
the beds and so it's kind of a
free-for-all and oftentimes results in
the most competitive weed common
lambsquarters a lot of times taking over
and producing thousands of weed seeds
and and that was dominating his weed
seed
and then a farmer that relies on hay
mulch for most of his crops I found had
a weed seed bank that was dominated by
annual grasses that are able to kind of
spread out and find some of the weak
spots with it in the hay mulch so with
all these examples I'm just trying to
show that no single strategy or no
single tactic is a hundred percent
effective on all weeds and so what we
need to do is to integrate in more weed
control tactics to provide more
broad-spectrum control and that's the
main point of integrated weed management
so I thought hey it would be ideal if
these growers could rotate between these
strategies and you know use each one
when it's when it's going to be most
effective and so I thought if I could
document some of the different benefits
and weaknesses of each strategy then
they could kind of use your kind of
prescribe each one based on each field
or each growing season to get the most
benefits from each one and so I actually
implemented each strategy and onions and
recorded the economic and ecological
effects a lot of the economic effects
were related to labor and the spread of
labor over time whether it be early in
the season or for the critical periods
throughout the season for zero seed rain
sporadic hand weeding from plastic
mulching or require one large mulching
event there are also some really
interesting ecological trade-offs here
yield was a little bit reduced in the
the light gray bar the critical period
and I should explain this is a spider
plot so so each
this is oriented so that as you go to
the periphery the the quantity is larger
so yield was a little bit decreased
under the critical period strategy some
of some of that weed biomass may have
may have affected yield and would
definitely make things tricky in the
future with all the weed seeds that were
produced under this strategy black
plastic mulch and the dark dotted line
had some positive effects on soil soil
quality but it also had decreased soil
microbial biomass which is an an
indicator of soil health
earthworms were most abundant under the
hay melt strategy with all that fodder
and then crab beetles which are
important seed predator were seemed to
prefer the weedy habitats of the
critical period plots and then insect
and disease damage was also greatest in
that critical period strategy so again
there's no overall best strategy here
but I'm hoping that organic farmers can
can use this kind of information on the
trade-offs to determine which strategy
is best for a particular field and
perhaps rotate between these strategies
more often so that was one part of my
dissertation the next part that I'm
going to go over was one in which I
tried to remove one of the main barriers
that is preventing some growers from
adopting or integrating in mechanical
weed control
so mechanical weed control typically is
very effective between the crop rows but
it oftentimes misses the weeds in the
row and and so that's the barrier that I
was going to try to talk
with with this research and there are
some some tools designed to to target
these in row weeds torsion weeders
finger leaders and tine harro's but
they're typically really lightweight and
flexible so that they don't damage the
crop and that unfortunately makes them
not very effective at controlling these
in row weeds but I took a look at one of
the one of a kind of a new breed of
cultivators that innovatively allows you
to use more than one in row tool at a
time and I found that yeah when you add
on more of these in row tools you
increase your efficacy which which makes
sense you kill more weeds some more
tools yeah but the really interesting
thing to me about this work was that
these particular tools in this
particular combination interacted in a
synergistic way and I can say that
because they killed more weeds than you
would have then you would expect based
on the performance of each individual
tool and I think what's going on here is
that when you're controlling weeds
mechanically or either undercutting
uprooting or burying weeds and you're
you're doing all three of those with
this combination I think that the the
torsion Wieters are undercutting weeds
and loosening the soil which allows the
finger leaders to uproot weeds more
effectively and then the Harrow
really we know that loose soil buries a
lot of weeds at the end so I was really
excited about this synergy and we're
getting very high weed control but the
problem here is the crop and so we were
actually killing around 15%
the crop which is not which is not exist
not acceptable
to a grower is there a video on it looks
like on the very top there's a video
camera looking down but maybe not oh
that's a drop wait that's that's pushing
the yeah there's in the Harrow down so
yeah this was an exciting result on the
one hand to get this really cool
synergistic effect but I was also taking
out a lot of the crop so when I got to
Cornell I wanted to continue to
investigate this synergistic effect but
try to make some changes that would
allow for less damage to the crop and so
what the first things I did was switch
out the torsion leaders which I think
we're we're undercutting a lot of the
crop for some basic sweeps which are
stay farther away from the crop I also
gave the crop more space between the
finger weeders here and then I took out
the the middle tines on the row Harrow
to allow the crop to pass through
I also investigated another tool so do
the the burying part at the very end as
the last part of the sequence this is a
mini disc Hiller and it can actually
throw soil into the crop row without
necessarily having the metal parts touch
the crop and then the other change at
Cornell Agrotech is that we have now a
GPS guided tractor which plants these
perfectly straight rows and then that
tractor was used to pull the cultivator
as well and so it was it was tracking on
the same rows that that I planted on so
I could be very precise with the
cultivation and as a result of those
changes this work was in snap beans Hey
the the crop mortality here
the beans in red what really was really
minimal so this was this was really
exciting but the mortality of the in row
weeds actually stayed high and so this
was this is a really exciting result for
me and and again the most effective
combinations or sequences were these
three tool sequences down the bottom and
here's another super slow-motion video
of one of the sequences that I was
really impressed with the sweeps
followed by the fingers followed by the
row hero and you can see that it's still
it's still aggressively working that in
rows own but it's not it's not knocking
the crop around nearly as much as the
previous video so yeah so this was a
good result and but I wanted to you know
so one of the things with this
particular trial is that it was really
in ideal conditions the beans were well
established they were at least six
inches tall whereas the weeds were made
less than one inch tall so it was it was
an ideal situation for this tool to work
so to really put this tool through the
paces I wanted to test it in a crop that
is slower to establish it's more slower
growing in a situation where the weeds
are right up around the same size as the
crop and silver for that I chose beets
and did several a couple trials so one
in in the two leaf stage and then one
trial in four leaf stage beets and you
can see in the in the red here that a
crop mortality of the two leaf stage was
unacceptable or killing around half the
crop and in some of these treatments
but if I waited until the four leaf
stage crop mortality was was reduced to
an acceptable level especially for this
particular combination of the sweeps
fingers disc killer and so this is just
a photo showing one of the one of the
few surviving beats from the tule stage
compared to the four leaf stage in which
the crop survived that that physical
disturbance fairly well and I think was
tall enough and it's in its morphology
to allow in that all that soil to bury
some of the lower growing weeds while it
remained above all that disturbance so
some of the impacts of this work include
that there's now more companies carrying
stacked cool tool combinations like this
company called till more that has a
small scale model a walk-behind model
and there's some larger companies as
well
or larger tools some growers aren't
necessarily shelling out the money for
for these new tools they're just
retrofitting their existing cultivator
by adding on parts that they happen to
have and have reported that it has
really improved the effectiveness so
that's that's kind of the that was the
early thrust of my work with New York
State IPM and I gave a lot of talks and
some demonstrations about about this
work and really I found that the
demonstrations are a lot better the
farmers farmers especially learn better
from demonstrations and hands-on type
learning rather than being lectured at
and so for the next part I'm going to
talk about some demonstrations that I
did and which I actually focused on
practices or tactics that I thought are
the underutilized in New York and so one
of the first ones was of solarization
which is the use of clear plastic to
superheat the soil and kill weeds and
potentially weed seeds and in this
demonstration in which I worked
alongside Brian Ashton our and and Betsy
Lam we demonstrated the solarization
plot and right next door had a control
plot and in each one
we buried temperature loggers about two
inches deep in the soil and found that
hay solarization increased the soil
temperature at two inch depths up into
the 120s and that's high enough to
actually kill some weed seeds so and and
there's been similar results up in Maine
and so this is really exciting because
solarization is typically used in
california and israel and and and hotter
and sunnier locations yeah so I think
that growers growers can start to use
civilization in New York to target their
weed seed bank and try to deplete the
number of seeds in the soil the next
demo I want to talk about was in
greenhouses for container production and
one of the or I guess several of them
more problematic weeds in container
production include wood sorrel here
liverwort
and oriental bitter craft and several of
these have the ability to actually eject
seeds from their mature seed pods up to
five or six feet away and they can land
they can go from the from the ground up
into the pots on the bench and so Brian
ash an hour and I had seen some research
from the USDA looking at at rice holes a
kind of a byproduct of rice processing
to use as a mulch and the USDA had some
initially kind of encouraging results
from that and so we looked at several
different rates from zero to a quarter
inch half inch and three quarter inch
and found that yeah the the the half
inch to 3/4 inch rates did really
effectively prevent these these seeds
from establishing even when we had had
hand to hand sewn them and there's
actually several growers in New York
that have adopted this practice ok the
next demonstration I want to talk about
is of controlling bindweed
in in grapes and you know grapes are
they're a perennial they're of a vining
crop and the growers have put all this
effort in to make these trellises and it
turns out that perennial vining weeds
really appreciate all that effort
especially behind weed and so and
growers a lot of time rely on glyphosate
to control bindweed sprayed in either
the fall or the spring but unfortunately
that's not the most effective time to
control buying weed with a systemic
herbicide more effective would be mid or
late summer and so Hans Walter Peterson
Don Caldwell and I evaluated several
treatments sprayed or implemented mid
summer so glyphosate kind of as a
standard as well as rim sulfur on a
group to herbicide cultivation and
untreated control and found that yes all
three of these treatments were were very
effective at controlling the the hedge
bindweed and in particular these two
treatments could have a bit of a benefit
in that they did not cause any visible
injury so
the grapes whereas the glyphosate did as
shown here okay so the final story I'm
going to tell today is is about I guess
probably my my biggest project so far
with New York State IPM and that's in
trying to find ways to control herbicide
resistant weeds in corn and soybean
systems here I'm holding up water hemp
which is only on maybe a dozen farms in
New York right now but it has growers I
think more worried than than the other
herbicide resistant weed I pictured
earlier horse weed because water hemp is
much more competitive and so we're
working with with most of these growers
to try to contain water hemp because
it's seed actually just Falls straight
to the ground
unlike horse weed which is windblown
windblown seed and is everywhere and the
growers wanted to know well which
herbicides exactly is water hemp
resistant to and so they sent me some
some seed samples and I gathered more
seed from other Extension educators and
actually grew out those seeds in in the
greenhouse this is in Tony de Tomaso's
greenhouse and then with help of his his
research associates Cathy Howard and
Scott Morris we actually sprayed several
different herbicides on these weeds to
determine if they were resistant or not
and the way we did that was spray
several different doses of each
herbicide to get this dose response
curve and we not only sprayed the the
population that we thought might be
resistant but I called over to a
colleague in Canada and got some
susceptible water hemp that that we knew
was susceptible to these herbs
and so if the two curves end up being
different then you can say that this
population is is resistant and so we
tested glyphosate we tested atrazine
tested a Mazda peer and in lacto fen and
it turned out that that we likely have
resistance from glyphosate from atrazine
and it matched appear but the lacto
Fionn was was still effective so that
was some good news for the growers and
the next part was to actually test these
herbicides and some more integrated
treatments out in the field as many of
you probably know conditions are a
little different and and processes work
differently out in the field than in the
greenhouse a lot of times and so the
first part for the first set of trials
which was in soybeans i looked at
several different herbicides and i've
replaced the names with just their their
site of action
what group number the herbicides are in
is just generally how they work so group
2 this is this was the this was the amaz
de pierre and then the atrazine or a
metro bution but another group five and
then two other different herbicide
groups represented just single
herbicides here used pre-emergence so
this is applied right at planting and
these herbicides are primarily acting on
the germinating weed seeds they don't
have as much activity on on necessarily
on the emerge plants and yeah this this
trial generally backed up the greenhouse
results in that group to the amaz de
pierre and in a group 5 were not
effective on controlling the water but
the next thing i did was you know so
these treatments here are not really
representative what a grower would
actually do so i included some
treatments that
more representative of of it 100% pre
only program a post only program so
these are this is sprayed midseason on
the emerged weeds and then a pre and a
post this is these are called to pass
programs and the final four here are
actually kind of rare right now in New
York most growers want to control all of
their weeds in one fell swoop they don't
want to have to drive through the field
twice so these were kind of my kitchen
sink approaches because we didn't know
how difficult it would be to control
this water hemp and so in the in the
contrast over here you can see generally
that the the two pass system was more
effective than the pre only or the post
only which makes sense one thing that
the growers are typically really
interested in is is how much do things
cost and as some backgrounds right now a
lot of growers are paying between ten
and twenty dollars an acre for weed
control maybe even less than ten dollars
an acre in some cases so that some of
these are getting up to $75 nacre that
is that's quite an increase especially
when you consider that soybean growers
are grossing four to five hundred
dollars an acre so say $400 an acre $75
out of that on weed control is quite a
big chunk but it might be worth it
actually because water hemp has seed
that is fairly short-lived in the soil
most of it will become enviable or will
have germinated after four years so it
might be worth it for a grower to you
know go with this really you know the
kitchen sink approach here spend the
money for four years deplete that water
hemp from the soil and then perhaps
scale back to a more
affordable weed control system otherwise
say the grower was getting 97% that's
still potentially several maybe ten or
twenty weeds per acre going to seed
producing thousands of seed and
perpetuating the problem so they may
have to spend sixty six dollars an acre
every year rather than for just a few
years so that's just something to
consider and the other aspect of the
trial was in corn I set up a similar
trial looking first at individual
herbicides again these are just their
group numbers group two and five were
the ones that we found resistance to in
the greenhouse and once again group two
was not not effective in controlling the
waterhemp but group five this time was
and I think part of that is just due to
the crop the corn is a more competitive
crop and so control is a little bit
easier and then with the full more
realistic treatments that a grower might
actually conduct once again pre only
versus post post only and then to past
systems and this time actually the the
pre by themselves was more effective
than post programs alone and then I was
particularly excited to see some of the
integrated treatments perform really
well so especially this system here you
know just one herbicide row cultivation
and then interceding controlled a
hundred percent of the water hemp for
those of you who aren't familiar with
either speeding it's kind of a hot new
topic for way for corn growers to
incorporate cover cropping into their
production driving around here there's
still a lot of corn even right now that
hasn't been harvested yet so for a
grower to try to
planting a cover crop after corn is
really challenging
so the interceding allows you to come in
and plant this cover crop when the corn
is maybe a foot or two tall the cover
crop slowly establishes over the course
of the season and then when the corn
dries down and then of course when you
harvest it the cover crop really takes
off and so this is this is a really
great practice for for soil health and
soil quality I wanted to make sure that
if growers are using more herbicides
especially residual herbicides the
pre-programs that that act on the weed
seeds that this wouldn't that those
herbicides wouldn't prevent you from
doing interceding so what I did was test
several different pre-emergents programs
and then followed by a post emergence
application that would not have any
residual effect on the seeds and then
planted annual rye grass as interceded
cover crop it came back in September
measured the annual rye grass biomass
and so any reductions here are likely
due to the residual herbicide I guess
except in the case of the untreated
control in which the cover crop was
competing with weeds but so the overall
effect was that or the overall message
is that those herbicides that have grass
weed activity did tend to injure the rye
grass but those that didn't like group
27 especially this is Callisto did not
enter the rye grass and so I would
suggest those are besides if growers are
looking to do interceding as well as
control these these broadleaf waterhemp
and horse weed one kind of
interesting anecdote about this that I'm
gonna be replicating this next year take
a closer look at is this potential
effect here of the row cultivation to
lessen the effect of the of the residual
herbicide I think that it kind of makes
sense in that the row cultivation would
break up the soil and help the residual
herbicide to degrade a little bit faster
so that wouldn't have as much of an
injury potential on the cover crops so
in these these field days I've
demonstrated interceding cultivation
different herbicide programs but what
are the growers think about this are
they are they going to change at all as
a result of these field days well one
thing I'm getting better at is
documenting my impact and a good way to
do that is by handing out evaluations at
the end of field days asking very
pointed questions as a result of this
program that's the pointed part which
practices will you increase in the next
few years and the results were we're
encouraging actually 27% of the growers
are likely going to be trying out to
past programs 34% are interested in
using several different herbicide modes
of action and that's that's kind of a
basic first step
not very many we're interested in the
road cultivation I think among
large-scale field crop growers it has
kind of a stigma or perception as being
really slow and that you're not going to
cover the acreage but I'm working on
changing that perception that some of
the newer cultivators are very fast 11%
interested in interceding and then this
was a surprise
17% interested in cleaning weed seeds
from equipment and it was a surprise
because we didn't we didn't really talk
about this in our programming at all if
this was well other than the fact that
after the growers left
the field days they had to clean their
boots really well and we gave them
brushes and everything and made them sit
down so they weren't spreading soil that
would contain these these weed seeds so
I think the growers are seeing you know
cleaning as a potentially low-cost way
to prevent the spread of these weeds one
other part of the project and this this
was kind of a fun part for me was
demonstrating a a weed zapper a tool
that was designed for use in soybeans
and it's actually an electrified rod
that runs over the top of the crop and
electrocutes any weeds that it comes in
contact with and this this is
particularly applicable to herbicide
resistant weeds horse weed here tends to
shoot up high above the soybeans as does
water hemp and so our other problem
weeds and so this was particularly
effective on those weeds and I'll
hopefully be looking into this more next
year along with Lin saws now ski and a
potential farm viability project looking
to the future and something that I'd
like to change a little bit as for next
year's trials is to investigate the use
of rye mulch to suppress weeds and this
is something that Matt Ryan has done a
lot of work with and/or inorganic
systems a great way that and in
conventional for that as well but
without herbicides a good way to
terminate this ride before planting the
soybeans into it is with a roller
crimper and in in some of Matt's trials
and Sarah petty Burgess trials that they
brought me in on I was really impressed
with how well the roll dry suppress
weeds and I think with our herbicide
resistant weeds it's going to be even
more effective
because both of our herbicide resistant
weeds horse weed and and waterhemp are
two primary ones they have tiny seeds
miniscule and they they have very little
energy stored inside them to push
through much residue at all
horse weed has to I mean when it emerges
from the soil it's typically in less
than a quarter inch of soil so I'm
hopeful that if I can try this next year
it'll be effective on these herbicide
resistant weeds and the other exciting
part of this this rye is that Sarah
petit bridge found that it's suppressed
white mold which is one of the primary
pathogens of soybeans suppressed white
mold by about 80 percent so roll dry I
mean it's a cover crop it's got great
soil health implications good potential
to control other pests or pathogens with
the roll dry and I'd like to see if it
can control our herbicide resistant
weeds as well so this is exactly the
kind of integrated type approach that
that I want to be demonstrating and you
know promoting just to sum things up
I've gone over a number of examples of
ways that that integrating different
herbicides and different tactics is
necessary to be to be most effective in
in weed control but a lot of times those
those tactics require more knowledge of
the ecology of the system they can be
more expensive and so to overcome those
challenges it really helps I think if
the alternative tactics also satisfy
other management goals like the roll dry
system that has multiple benefits for
farms and with that I want to thank
Newark farm viability Institute for
finding the corn and soybean work USDA
nifA for the cultivation research
northeast air for the systems comparison
and then the Lake Erie regional grape
Research & Extension Program and New
York wine and grape foundation for the
bind weed control research and I'll take
any questions
[Applause]
rice whole containers cuz I've seen this
everywhere really okay yeah yeah so the
question for people online is is how
does the rice haul mulch work and what
are the what's the mechanism I guess and
from what I've read it sounds like the
rice haul mulch is just so dry and even
after it's watered it's so light and
dries out so quickly that doesn't
provide a kind of a safe site for seeds
to germinate clean I mean if you put it
on in the spring before many weeds these
were growing Louise might be in the soil
right yeah
we didn't test whether or not the rice
Hamas would suppress existing weeds in
the soil their weed seeds yeah we we
applied the mulch and then sprinkled the
seeds on top as if they had just been
you know shot from the plant which at
the time it sounded like the more the
more common way that just yeah yeah so I
suppose it would be more applicable for
annual plants in which are starting with
Queens usually clean potting mix
- how come yeah it could be from from
what I read it from the USDA's trial
they were indicating that the primary
mechanism was the drawing yeah yeah
Betsy yeah
the waterhemp came in likely well for
several of the farms based on how it
came into their their kind of tractor
storage area and how that coincided with
how they recently purchased used
equipment from the Midwest I think
that's probably the likely scenario
other times it can come in on
contaminated seed or more commonly on
contaminated bedding if it's a dairy
farm if they're getting feather meal or
other types of you know inputs like that
from other states it's not right easy
access yeah it's a good point
yeah Brian for many years there's been a
weed suppression or weed killing
technique of a flame to remove have you
experimented with those at all and if so
have you seen if they have any true
value yeah good question Don so have I
do I have experience with the flame
we're and I haven't personally done
research with the flame year I have used
one but yeah they're very effective I
mean you're you're you're burning the
the existing vegetation of the plant in
some cases although the manufacturers
suggest and some research suggests that
you only need to pass by just fast
enough to rupture some of this
eles in the plant so that when you
squeeze the leaf your your thumb leaves
a mark and that indicates that you've
done enough damage that the plant will
likely die yet flame weeding is really
effective on annual broadleaf weeds it's
not quite as effective on grass weeds
because they're growing point they're
you know they're meristematic tissue is
kind of protected and lower and then of
course perennials it's not as effective
on either yeah yeah when you had your
that kanva volatility nations and they
think oh that's a good question Lin yeah
so Dai Kamba Dai canva and has been in
the news a lot for volatility and and
growers are concerned especially in
areas that are near grapes that are
extremely sensitive to group for
synthetic auxins in general that yeah we
need to be really careful about about
applying group for herbicides according
to the label and I hadn't actually seen
that what you mentioned about the
glyphosate lowering the pH and
potentially increasing the volatility do
you know that hasn't made it to the
label yet has it any restrictions on
that response to this combination so I
was just wondering if you give in your
research if you feel you see any enhance
all ability
yeah I mean we yeah it's it's so you
know it's it's it's an invisible you
know I didn't receive any calls the day
after but we were spraying on such small
plots that that we wouldn't have seen it
for the trial I'm sure we have had some
die kamba injury though in New York from
from volatilized applications and I
believe there's there's resources online
if if grape growers feel like they have
some injury to the grapes that they can
document that and try to narrow down it
was there a farm in the vicinity that
was spraying and drinks a certain time
and potentially they could they could
get a payment to reimburse them for the
damage right before we're at luck and
you just ask Geneva there are any
questions yes any questions from Geneva
do I have to do anything on here great
well thanks very much Brian this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at Cornell edu